well it tastes really good
how's your head
mushy
i'm sorry that i yelled at you
all three times
but i don't think you know anything
about my department
have you ever been part of a government
body before uh i have yeah
a small town called partridge minnesota
why does that sound familiar
you're benji wyatt i am when i was 18 i
ran for mayor of my small town
and won
a little bit of anti-establishment voter
rebellion i guess here's the thing
though about 18 year olds they're idiots
so i pretty much ran the place into the
ground after two months and got
impeached
worst part was my parents grounded me
oh my god you were so cute oh thank you
what was that song you played at the
swearing-in ceremony
whoop there it is that's what it was
god i was so jealous of you you
shouldn't have been i mean it ended up
kind of ruining my life
and now i'm i'm balancing budget so i
can show people i'm responsible so
i can run for office again someday and
not be laughed at now
i mean you want to run for office
someday right
yeah
how'd you know well you have to be able
to make decisions like this leslie you
have to be harsh you know
no one's gonna elect you to do anything
if you don't show that you're
responsible responsible grown-up
yeah
ah well
oh no please mr mayor let me
okay
on the house leslie oh thank you
i'm sort of a gay hero
last year i married two penguins at the
zoo and it turned out they were both gay
penguin wedding uh-huh that's cute it
was so cute
but enough about how cute it was why
don't you think i should have the money
good lord really look when i was 18 and
i became mayor of my hometown
i used every last dollar we had to open
a giant winter sports complex call it
ice time and it turned out great and
everyone loved it uh yeah kinda it was
never completed and i got impeached
newspaper headline was ice town costs
ice clown his town crown
luck
they were big into rhymes well
i don't i think ice town sounds great
and the point is at least you tried
something
hey thanks leslie but you know what we
really want to do today is have a chat
with ben wyatt here come on ben come on
ben i'm more of a behind the scenes well
let's either come with us or get in the
spank chair so
maybe it's time for an interview come on
everybody come on come on over back yeah
so this guy ben wyatt we're looking him
up on alta vista
he's from some hicktown partridge
minnesota and when he's 18
he's elected mayor
[Music]
that's funny that's funny he's 18
becomes the mayor and then blows the
whole budget on an ice skating rink city
goes bankrupt no
you're out of there what'd you what'd
you call it again
what was it called
say it
ice town
[Laughter]
i was a kid and um when you
you
you you end up getting out there and uh
and there's uh i really wish you guys
could see this guy right now he is
dronched in sweat
there's also gonna be ponies at the
harvest festival all right let's take a
caller from douche nation all right talk
to me caller sup guys just douching over
here in eagleton sweet
seems like 18 is pretty young for a
mayor what were you like 12
the funny um
when
i guess
the fortunate um
can we just
sort of
game over man game over
nice job man was that your first time
talking to other people cause it came
off that way you embarrassed me in front
of the douche i'm sorry you guys i just
i haven't had to deal with that mayor's
stuff for 17 years i guess i'm not
totally over it no worries look it's
just a bump in the road
fortunately the leslie mobile is an
all-terrain vehicle
so everything involving ben is fine i
just need to talk to you in private
about something different that is not
been related ben good job
ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who are
you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine i mean
you know sometimes i feel like i might
need glasses is there a bird in here i
swear i keep seeing a bird in the studio
maybe that's kind of the same
he was fine until bird started asking
about the boy mayor's stuff what's wrong
with you you look psychotic i was 18
when i was elected mayor okay so excuse
me for that cindy eckert had just turned
me down for senior prom do you know how
that feels i should call her i should i
no i shouldn't and i'm not going to and
i'm proud of myself for that
hello and welcome to pawnee today i'm
joan callamezzo today's guest is leslie
knope who's here to tell us how this
year's harvest festival is going to
bankrupt the city
well joan actually there's a lot of
false information flying around the
harvest festival is jumping right in
it's rude
i just want everyone to know what an
extraordinary event this is going to be
but at what cost
how many cities does ben wyatt need to
destroy before he's put behind bars ben
wyatt has done nothing wrong
you know
if you want to ask him questions let's
go for it huh let's ask any question
about his past or present just get it
over with ben let's get up here yeah
yeah come on
we'll just ask him a bunch of questions
and then we'll get everything cleared
and out of the way sound good yeah great
good
uh let's take some calls joan
why don't you okay uh caller are you
there
yeah how can you justify raising taxes
for something that'll hurt the town
i
for
yeah why should we trust this ben wyatt
guy
because i'm trustee trust me i'm
trustworthy
and
i am working very hard to
make sure that this town gets back on
its feet there we go okay great next
caller
so i looked you up on alta vista and i
found out that the last seven towns
you've gone to ended up bankrupt
okay first of all
why does everyone in this town use alta
vista
is it 1997 and second i am a budget
specialist i went to those towns because
they were bankrupt and now they aren't
and yeah i screwed up when i was 18. but
who doesn't do dumb stuff when they're
18.
joan
stole my gym teacher's husband
so there you
go okay move a little bit to your left
and then turn to the side okay and
freeze
that is the exact spot
where an 18 year old ben wyatt was
inaugurated as mayor of partridge
minnesota ah well thank you very much
yes congratulations to you oh i have
chills i can't believe they're finally
giving me the key to the city i can't
believe it took so long they gave the
key to every other mayor in the town's
history and i guarantee that none of
them had as cute to butt as you do and
none of them caused the city's
unemployment rate to hit 30 percent
you're so sexy when you talk about
percentages
when ben was mayor he sunk all of the
town's money into a winter sports
complex called icetown and they went
bankrupt
now they've invited him back as a
gesture of goodwill and he'll finally
get some closure on this miserable
chapter in his life
yay ben town hero yes
but now 20 years later
the city has finally healed
from the festering wound
of icetown today
we put those horribly painful memories
behind us as we welcome back the mayor
who made all of that possible
ben wyatt
oh that's a typo that's a major typo
that says ice clown
i'm just realizing now that's not a typo
hey aren't you his sister
i got to get out of here good luck
leslie
my friend jack and i used to fish this
lake in the summer
one time
our boat almost tipped over but then it
didn't
it's not a great story yeah i had a
pretty uneventful
childhood i got you something
no way
yeah where did you get that i stole it
from mayor stice's office screw that guy
you should have it you're the best wife
in the world
but i don't want this really
yeah i mean i love partridge but i have
pawnee now
and i have you well i'm not giving it
back to stice that guy sucks yeah
well you know what then
hey
lake's not a garbage can pal yeah sorry
it was symbolic is that ben wyatt
get the hell out of here ice town okay
go go go
you